sarah michelle gellar teases new details
about the cruel intentions TV reboot
better batter pitcher can you say that
can you say that now
remember back in 1999 when this saucy
movie came out don't you get it you're
just a toy Sebastian a little toy I like
to play with well it's coming back this
time to TV Sarah Michelle Gellar says
it's going to be epic I think it's you
know it's 17 years later and we didn't
tell the story until we had a great
story to tell and I think we have
something really unique and really
different see how everybody does it it's
just that nobody talks about it these
days when SFG isn't playing Kathryn more
toys she's running her company food
stirs which sells baking kits for kids
for me my greatest inspiration has been
my children ultimately as a parent you
want to teach your children that they
can accomplish anything and when it
comes to cooking together as a family
the actress says her hubby Freddie
Prinze jr. leads the way he's really the
expert I I bring the experience and the
sweet treat but he's the the he's the
main man real-deal experience in the
kitchen